when faced with criticism the media will
say it's their job to hold people
accountable like that my pillow guy at
the briefing what a dork
I think these briefings could be I think
better designed the president could come
out say a few words in terms of what his
administration is doing not have these
you know PR stunts like mr. pillow
coming out and giving a plug for his
company
it's obviously above my pay grade I
don't make the call but we take them or
not but it seems crazy to me that
everyone's still taking them when you
got the my pillow guy getting up there
talking about reading the Bible uh-huh
reading the Bible but it wasn't just TV
non-essential bozos with blue checkmarks
also took to Twitter to mock Mike Lynn
Dell but while these turds snark away
Lyndell was converting his business into
making 50,000 masks a day so yeah laugh
all you want the object of your ridicule
will save lives
fact is Lynn Dell is an American success
story but because he mentions the Bible
too much he's worthy of media scorn
because they're so much better than him
so as we strive to unite against one of
the greatest foes we've ever faced you
got to ask does that really help and
does this help do you think there is
blood on the president's hands
considering the slow response or is that
too harsh of a criticism I think that's
a little too harsh hmm once again the
media frames this pandemic as their
divisive playground for them the perfect
medication is a cheap shot I wonder when
the five sounded the alarm on the virus
back in January what was Chuck's concern
I think that one of the reasons the
Senate Republicans want to get this over
with as quickly as possible because you
want the maximum amount of time between
whatever this is and the voters voting I
think if you look at what happened in
the summer of 2016 leaving aside the
election itself Zika virus
Orlando nightclub shooting there's going
to be a lot of news in the next nine
months and última rotavirus that is
clearly a this is going to impact China
and ways in our economy that we haven't
really contemplated concerned about
China's economy not the American people
now who has blood on their hands so you
chuck the blood on your hands game can
be extended indefinitely to everyone
trying to put the unknown virus in
context of other illnesses like the
media did then they have blood on their
hands if you told Americans to go about
your business like our New York
politicians did then you have blood on
your hands if you in the media conflated
the name of a drug for fish tank cleaner
then you have blood on your hands
at some point no one has spotless hands
including Chuck which is why we got to
dump this gaucho of BS it helps no one
my advice time to wash our hands of the
blood on your hands line then maybe the
press can find a real question one that
seeks an answer instead of attention all
right Jesse sit say you you had
mentioned this before in the a block
what do you what's your take on the
attack on poor mr. pillow man the media
snobs don't think mike has the corporate
pedigree to be at the Rose Garden the
media snobs hold technology executives
in very high regard but they look down
on industrialists on manufacturers on
the Procter & Gamble's United
Technologies and jockeys and really look
down on people that use infomercials to
sell their product like Mike what really
set them off first was saying read the
Bible they don't understand mike is a
recovering addict that's an affirmation
for him everybody understands that
people recovering from addiction do that
and it's important to them other thing
to understand is whenever a culture is
challenged by a war a pandemic and
economic depression the culture always
digs deeper into their faith it's
happened throughout history every single
time and the fact that the media doesn't
have the empathy for that the business
intelligence the compassion to
understand that really just makes me
realize how shallow they are on Chuck
Todd and Nancy we're at war you can
either be with us or you can be against
us there's some people in this country
that are trying to help and there's some
people in this country who are trying to
divide listen the president the
Democrats no one has been perfect we
were slow with the testing but very
quick
the travel ban and that's been much more
critical in saving lives we can play
this game all day about who was positive
who was negative and when that happened
Nancy Pelosi just a couple weeks ago was
in downtown San Francisco telling
everybody to go to Chinatown getting a
big crowd go to the restaurants and shop
she was telling everybody about
impeachment while this virus was
spreading Chuck Todd moderated a
Democratic presidential debate just a
little while ago
you know how many questions he asked
about the virus zero we can do this all
day long it's not important but what is
important now is everybody needs to get
on the same page and help I thought you
were gonna go all day huh take it you
know there's a weird media hypocrisy in
which if a religious person does
something really bad if you mention the
religion you're a bigot but if somebody
who's very religious does something good
you can make fun of them mercilessly so
you might be Islamophobic if you talk
about terrorism but you can make fun of
Michael and Dale because you know he
mentions the Bible and people who read
the Bible or just a bunch of idiots
according to the media right and if you
don't make fun of those people who cite
scripture who believe in a higher power
as part of their recovery and their life
and their effort to give back if you
don't make fun of those people you're
not getting invited to Chuck Todd's
cocktail soiree that he's surely gonna
throw for all his left-wing liberal
buddies when all this is over but that
goes to the point we're a nation that
roots for recovery and redemption we're
a nation of people who believe in second
chances
so I think all of these people who've
sit in front of TVs for a living need to
go in their boudoir or their man cave
and look in the mirror and ask
themselves am i rooting for catastrophe
for death for dying for suffering
because I think it might benefit myself
somehow and I might have more power
because I think they need a real hard
check and a hard look in the mirror and
ask themselves at the end of the day do
I just need to shut up yeah you
one you are a god-fearing man you go to
Mass every Sunday I am NOT I'm a guy I'm
an agnostic I reflect probably more of
the media than you do in that sense dude
does it bother you when you see that
they kind of look down their noses that
somebody for being for openly talking
about God and the Bible well yeah sure
would cuz they'd be looking down at me
yes but I I don't I didn't take it the
way that you did though I saw it as
people saying that Michael and L stood
up there and he started making political
statements about like divine
intervention in November of 2016 when
Trump won so he turned it into something
of a political rally when it was
intended to be a briefing for the
American people on the coronavirus I
think President Trump even said you know
I'm surprised he said that signaling to
me that he didn't set it up I don't know
but it did it didn't seem appropriate I
guess to the president even my bigger
point though in regard to you know the
Chuck Todd thing is I think that you're
right and that was a divisive kind of
statement it wasn't about insider
information it was about setting up a
fight let me hold your jacket while you
two goes you know head-to-head I didn't
think that was right but I do think that
if it's about the question of
mobilization right now you know America
is mobilized for action in dealing with
this virus if that's the right response
now why was it why can't you say hey
that would have been the right response
earlier would have been with the right
response a month ago so to me if that's
the direction of the journalist Chuck
Todd going there I would say that's
informational that's legitimate let's
just look at where we are what we're
doing but setting up a phony fight and
even as you heard former Vice President
Biden he said hey I wouldn't say that
that's too harsh that's too far I think
that the problem with that question
about questioning how fast one should do
something can be applied to every single
good thing in life because every single
good thing in life could be started
sooner but that will save that Dana I
keep hearing a train is that in your
town in the background can you hear it I
can hear the train
I was worried you would think it was my
stomach I can recognize that New Jersey
train anywhere because I been there I
know the trance
it's your backyard as it came by
yesterday too so I would say three
things I remember when I was press
secretary there was a one Network News
reporter I'm not going to name him and I
remember as the deputy press secretary
one time being in the room where they
were all watching this on the screens
where the president was giving a speech
and at the end of the speech the
president said may God bless you may God
bless america
and this reporter slammed his hands on
the table and said I can't stand it I
can't take it anymore all this God talk
and he was like screaming this in the
room and I was just shocked but then I
realized they would make fun of George W
Bush for being a faithful person all the
time the second thing I would say is
asking a question of blood on your hands
is a real cliche ya know it's like it's
just like it's an easy one it's sort of
like when somebody says how would you
what grade would you give yourself for
their own environment like those
questions to me are so lazy
yeah but also let's say something nice
about Joe Biden you didn't take the bait
and you said no I think that's a little
too harsh I mean that was very statesman
like and he should get some credit for
that you know the only person you can I
probably ask you know do you have blood
on your hands is OJ Simpson right I mean
because it is so not to his face now to
his face that dude's face and if he's
holding a knife run let me ask you yes
do you think any of these reporters
would ask President Xi that same
question I probably not that is a good
question but you know I can't read minds
but yeah I think it's just it's one of
those fallback questions that we just
could I wish you'd just get rid of it
it's it's it's yeah it's only it's a way
of just a grading question out yeah
Jesse your turn you know question the
difference is this is Meet the Press
I don't think Chuck has the chops to
host that show but regardless the White
House Corona Task Force but I think the
brief very
and we're gonna wait for that and people
who don't practice social distancing
could end up behind bars the mayor of
Washington DC threatening 90 days in
jail for residents who violate her stay
at home order offenders could also be
facing a hefty $5,000 fine the mayor now
backtracking a little bit says she want
to enforce that order with a heavy hands
and take a look at this scene coming out
of LA a huge line of police officers
were forced to break up a birthday party
for a one-year-old because around 40
people attended no one was arrested in
that city's attempt to enforce a stay at
home order one these governors are these
local officials they have a lot of power
in a time like this
some are using it smartly some are using
it a little heavy-handed lis but it's
all on them how do you think it's
shaking out across the country well this
is my personal experience just because
I'm in DC and so last night when I went
for a walk with my wife I went down by
the local recreation center and there
was a guard on guard standing by the
tennis courts by the basketball courts
and the and the the acquit you know this
is the swimming arena they're keeping
people out telling if you can't play
tennis you can't get on the basketball
court a guard I was like I've never seen
anything like this but what's good about
this is that there's coordination so you
have Ralph Northam who's the governor in
neighboring Virginia you have Larry
Hogan who's the governor neighboring
Maryland all issuing stay-at-home orders
now the mirrors you said in DC walked it
back up it says we're not trying to put
people in jail but we want to make sure
they get the message that right now
social distancing is helping us is
helping America to slow the right the
rate of this virus spreading